should I change my shirt or you just
wear the same shirt for all videos yeah
for three years I've been wearing I
rønneberg now I just I just wear the
same shirt for like four videos in a row
do you put them like right up
back-to-back usually sometimes I spread
them apart that people go why are they
wouldn't sink yeah it'll look weird if
you're changing yeah I'm just liking the
same shirt okay yeah okay so don't make
me look at my channel don't make me look
bad
all right I want your challenge do
whatever you want
anyway guys we're gonna watch Dwayne
Johnson and Kevin Hart's new movie
teaser trailer Central Intelligence
I made Lauren uncomfortable with the
last video that we filmed so I'm have to
tone down the vulgarity in this video
okay guys thank you baby
I already successfully made her
uncomfortable okay spoiler alert I'm in
the CIA
are you joking with me right now
bottom line are you in or you out well
then I'm out
actually you're already in it won't you
ask because I thought you would go I'm
in Bob and we would have had a really
cool moment but you kind of ruin the
whole thing
take my gut we may have to kill some
people don't do no such thing I think
you'll like it ha
I need your skill set to save the entire
free world you ready no sweet let's go
oh let's me remember saying that I was
out I know but they think you're right
hahahaha please if we split up you know
haven't even stood up bah
I got a plan
my get us both killed absolutely they
totally bust or cool
you're the coolest kid in the high
school like a total transformation used
to be oh my god oh god oh I love the
tagline it takes a little heart and a
big Johnson like know it it's heavy yeah
if that I thought was a tagline it takes
a little hot it takes a little heart and
a big Johnson that's like my philosophy
of life wait no I have to come down the
bulgarians this video I was about to
like beat that joke to the grandpappy no
no well I really like from that trailer
that very least advertising was like
Dwayne Johnson looks like he's rocketed
in the comedy role I expect more like
Dwayne Johnson be the straightforward
guy and then and then Kevin Hart would
be like the wacky comedian but it seems
like Kevin Hart's more of the guy with a
you know a sharp head and then Dwayne
Johnson kind of seems like a little
naive and dumb but he's like the badass
action hero at the same time so I'm
excited to see them come together like
that they look like they're having a
blast yeah yeah I know definitely he
looked like really cool and really
awesome the whole CIA thing I like did
you watch him on um what's that show us
at ballers I haven't seen ballers yet
yeah that's when I started like
following him because it's like oh wow
he's kind of cool then I was like follow
my Instagram so I follow him on
Instagram do you like that kind of
muscle you know I really honestly like I
was never really into that kind of
muscle because like I have this
philosophy where like if a guy looks
better than I do then like we can't be
seen together so like I guess in theory
it's nice but no I'm not really into
that but you know it's better real it's
a real complex like I can't I can't date
a guy who's like more fit or hotter than
me have you ever dated a guy who's like
actually more fit than you know Wow
no actually oh I have like hooked up
with guys that were more fit than me but
then it just didn't go anywhere because
I just was like I can't go on a second
date with you you're just too damn
good-looking you're making me look bad I
feel like um my girlfriend and you have
the same philosophy I mean but at the
same time I'm kind of like I'm way
hotter than my girlfriend like I'm Way
more physically fit I'm just I mean when
I saw your girlfriend I was just like
wow like you did really good I know it's
a shocker for everyone no one expects my
girlfriend to be so hot when they see
her almost every comment is like and
when she's in a video with me is how the
[ __ ] did he get her he's so fat and
stupid or something like that
I mean yeah it's me it's mean but I just
laugh and point my middle finger at them
cuz I'm the one who gets hurt I really
liked when he was in high school he
looked really cute yeah he did I feel
like Kevin Hart could pull off a good
haircut like that yeah totally I like it
like very safe by the Bell oh yeah
totally same by the Bell was a [ __ ] bag
man the action and it looks pretty cool
too like that car crash I saw you like
yeah yeah yeah exactly I'm I'm much more
frightful than you are when it comes to
things like that
yeah the action in it actually looks
really sweet and I like seeing a cool
action comedy a lot of times you get
like action comedy and they're either
more of a comedy than an action film I
feel like this will have a cool balance
of showcasing both and it's just cool to
see the rock is just having so much fun
that's like my favorite thing is when I
see him just having a blast on screen
because look at him he could be so
serious all the time but he's really
just a giant muscular teddy bear yeah
he's got those eyes see black no no
looks like black Filipino yeah yeah
maybe you're you know related somehow
well as you got a Dwayne Johnson you
know I mean sorry Lauren
I can't help it it's a disease okay it
kind of does look similar to ride-along
did you see that no with Kevin Hart and
ice cube work ice cubes a cop and Kevin
Hart wants to be a cop there's so many
of these I was telling you there's some
Martin Lawrence movie about this too
it's like there's always like the guy
was the guy who's cop and the guy wants
to be cop and now like the thing with
CIA I feel like there's so many freaking
television shows about the CIA what I
like though is that Kevin Hart doesn't
want to be a part of it but he's being
forced to be a part of it instead of
just him being the buddy who's along
with the CIA agent the CIA agent is like
no you you're part of the CIA now oh the
fact Wayne Johnson oh I love that part
fat Dwayne Johnson right
dancing yeah he's like would you still
be in a Dwayne Johnson if you look like
that yes more oh yeah more so that he
looks like to muscular cuz then I told
you like it's gonna make me look bad in
my photos he'd be like oh he's so
good-looking who is that girl with them
but then sew them work physically unfit
the guy is better the better it is for
you yes I really feel like my girlfriend
took on your philosophy they go well I
think a lot of girls like that really
yeah so you would date like a big fat
guy I have you have yes Wow
woman are a lot more humble than I
expected them to be these days look at
your dog she has a little doggie here
yeah he attacked your cats well he
didn't he tried to play with them and
your cat was just like I'm sorry that my
cat responded like how a cat would
respond to a dog but yeah central
intelligence looks like a fun movie
can't really think of anything bad to
say about it good marketing good
marketing on you guys nothing really
negative except that they didn't have me
and the movie guys Lauren needs work any
work she needs to be cast in more stuff
yeah no porn joke seriously real film
Hey I'm defending you okay I'm trying to
make you look better
all right great I feel like you're not
appreciative of the effort I've been
putting in I'm so so appreciative guys
guys appreciate Mike yeah working my ass
off and make you look good anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel
listen correct if you're new to it you
can subscribe today by clicking this
button in between our heads Lauren has a
channel I want my Lauren and it's a
great comedy channel seriously there's a
lot of funny ass sketches on there if
you guys like sketches check it out and
there's one sketch celebrity grabs your
boob not gonna say this love is but good
tease for you guys thanks guys can you
look good Amy look good leave a nice
comment for me in the comments tell him
how awesome I am yes please please know
everyone's gonna love you Lauren
Nik Perales shout out please hey guys
huge fan of the channel love you guys
and I have a huge crush on Elissa be
crazy you don't know she is she is my
wife and Jerry is life - you don't know
who Jerry is my best friend my bro I
love him do anything for him and Ryan
lets me take me lol let's seriously
though you guys make my damn life better
by making me smile love you guys
Nick / Alice it makes me so happy to
know that we make your day better I'm
gonna do a judgment of you based off
your photos let's see if he has any
photos of himself he doesn't okay the
fact that you don't have any photos of
your actual self shows me that you have
a chance of getting Lauren cuz chances
are you're not attractive you're very
overweight probably have braces still
for like a 20 year old and you snore
when you sleep all the Lawrence types as
long as she looks more attractive in the
end when compared to you so Nick good
luck buddy
you have a chance take care